gather your wits about you word Smiths
because the word we're talking about
today is resource food in the pantry
diamonds in the mind wealth brain power
resource it's a noun it means wealth
money minerals land or other useful
things we can think of Natural Resources
as things that come from the land like
Timber or stone or even things like
clean air and fresh water these are
resources too to be cherished and
protected
but it could also mean just like money
um someone with a lot of resources at
their disposal might have a lot of cash
or
connections the derivation of this word
is intriguing to me it comes from the
French word resour which means a spring
like a natural source of water and that
ultimately comes from the
Latin which means to rise up to rise
once more uh Reay or re right means back
or again or against and Sur or Source
means to push up or forward like a wave
so let's see what we can make out of
those word Parts re and Sur and and
Source 10 seconds putting on music let's
kick
[Music]
it okay here's what I've got resourceful
which is an adjective meaning clever and
capable a resourceful person knows what
to do in a pinch surge which is a noun
or a verb that means to push forward
like a wave right a power surge or or
like a crowd surging forward at a
concert using re again we've got
resonate which is to sound again uh
something that resonates is literally
something that Echoes right Reon to
sound again and figuratively is
something that makes you feel a
connection the echo is happening inside
of you let's try using resource in a
couple of sentences so you can see some
of the ways that we can use it first
let's use it in the noun form there's a
lot of interest in using the ocean's
Tides as a renewable energy resource so
the tides are a source of electrical
power which is one of the ways in which
they might be valuable to a society
personally I like how the tides expose
little bits of beach glass that I
collect in jars but that's that's just
me let's talk about the adjective form
resourceful someone who is good at
marshalling resources to meet their
needs Captain Corey was a very
resourceful pirate always repurposing
bits of shipwrecks to upgrade his own
vessel he took advantage right of those
resources that were available as he
sailed past
shipwrecks however those shipwrecks
happened to occur stay resourceful
wordsmiths you can learn anything dve it
out